[Musik]
die Leute greifen bei Männern wie mir
immer zu drastischen Maßnahmen ich habe
grundsätzlich meine 9mm dabei gehabt
beim abendlichen Spaziergang durch
Hamburg hat der Mann zu dem diese Stimme
gehört maximal ein neues Smartphone weiß
ich vor 20 Jahren ging Jan Sander auch
Miami Gianni genannt das letzte Mal
durch das Rotlichtviertel der Hansestadt
hier war eher Türsteher alle kannten ihn
nur wenig später macht er sich in der
Szene als Zuhälter erinnern er wäre noch
heute perfekt für den zwielichtigen Job
fast 2 m groß breit wie ein
Wohnzimmerschrank und mit Oberarmen die
manche Oberschenkel haben graublaue
Augen funkeln aus dem braun gebrannten
Gesicht mit Dreitagebart heraus aber der
Blick ist nicht aggressiv er aufgeweckt
und weich und passt nicht so recht zur
restlichen martialischen Erscheinung des
42-Jährigen aber diese Augen haben viel
gesehen Miami Gianni weiß Bescheid über
die Kriminellen Spielchen auf der
Reeperbahn zur Genüge damals wie heute
das war damals bekannt in Hamburg das
tue ich jetzt Leon scheckkartenbetrug
sehr viel Gelder eingenommen werden es
war bekannt dass grundsätzlich auch 18
19 20 jährige zur Prostitution nicht
unbedingt gezwungen werden aber
überredet werden zur meiner Zeit und das
ist bis heute auch so geblieben war die
Marek Bande sehr aktiv mit eigenen
hinter blissmas Clubs sowie
Zimmervermietung die Hells Angels und
auch Albaner aber auch die
Türsteherszene war damals schon hart
umkämpft immer so immer mehr Albaner
mich damit und gleichzeitig auch Iraner
und natürlich die Türken die waren sehr
aktiv auf vorbei, was keiner ahnte der
immer fitte respektierte und teils
geflüchtete Miami Gianni führt ein
gefährliches Doppelleben
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
bild
der V-Mann undercover im Rotlichtmilieu
Jenny arbeitet damals für das
Landeskriminalamt in Hamburg und sammelt
heimlich für die Polizei wichtige
Informationen im Kies jetzt und hier
packt er über seine Vergangenheit aus
[Musik]
Anfang 2000 immer wieder erbrechen
Revier Kriege zwischen den Zuhälter
Beamten aus Schlägereien Messerangriffe
sogar Schüsse sind an der Tagesordnung
die Hackordnung auf dem Kiez wird sehr
blutig aus gekämpft es geht
hauptsächlich um Frauen und das Geschäft
welche verweht anschafft und um sich
Millionen D-Mark die Polizei verstärkt
zunehmend ihre Präsenz auf der
Reeperbahn regelmäßig finden in
Bordellen und lauf Häusern gatien Stadt
ermittelt wird gegen die Betreiber wegen
Steuerhinterziehung
Menschenhandel und sexuelle Ausbeutung
was mein Schwerpunkt war in
Zusammenarbeit mit den Behörden da lag
mein Fokus grundsätzlich immer auf
Gewaltdelikte gegen Frauen auf auf
schwere Gewalttaten zum Nachteil von
Frauen ich habe Sachen erlebt im im
Rotlichtmilieu da muss man leider Gottes
sagen meistens Zugang durch durch
Ausländer das ist normal so nah gerade
die Diez Alter vom Balkan oder auch aus
der Türkei die nehmen da überhaupt keine
Rücksicht für die zählt einfach nur der
finanzielle Prophet es gab Situationen
in denen ich wegschauen musste
weil ich
dann aufgeflogen wäre und das sind
natürlich so Sachen die nimmst du auch
mit nach Hause und Jan ist zu Hause ist
der Kiez der bekommt täglich die
Stimmung unter den Kriminellen mit ist
Teil des Zähne und wandelt immer auf dem
schmalen Grat zwischen Beobachter und
Täter ich kann mich da an eine Situation
erinnern da habe ich von einer
Informanten den Hinweis bekommen dass
wohl in einem billig Bordell eine
Minderjährige anschaffen soll zu unserem
Erstaunen war diese angeblich
Minderjährige im Besitz eines deutschen
Personalausweises der sie als 24
jähriger aus wie es doch danach
stellte sich raus
dass die
überprüfte Person im Besitz eines
gefälschten Ausweises sein und
nicht nur minderjährig sei sondern
gerade mal 13 Jahre alt ist
Janni tauscht sich der noch regelmäßig
mit den LKA Beamten aus die Auto dafür
sind beliebig und in der Öffentlichkeit
sie dürfen nicht auffallen deshalb
treffen sich die Männer häufig
konspirativ im Restaurant eines
Kaufhauses bei Kaffee und Kuchen denn
die Polizei Hamburg setz den Bereich
organisierte Kriminalität Kurzvokal
genannt sogenannte Vertrauensleute ein
sie sind ein wichtiges Mittel zur
Aufklärung schwerer Straftaten
Timo Zill Pressesprecher der Polizei
Hamburg lebt in seinem schmucklosen büro
an einer großen Tasse Kaffee er weiß
dass der Einsatz von V-Leuten sehr
umstritten ist gerade was die
organisierte Kriminalität aber auch
Rechtsextremismus betrifft trotzdem
sieht er die gewinnbringenden Aspekte
deutlich Paulaner sind für uns in diesem
Milieu extrem wichtig es ist natürlich
ein sehr sehr abgeschlossener Bereich
ist wird unwahrscheinlich viel Geld
damit gemacht zu großes Elend häufig
reden wir ja auch über Sex und
Ausnutzung von osteuropäischen Frauen
und der deswegen habe natürlich ein
hohes Maß an Interesse dort tätig zu
werden und das gelingt uns häufig eben
nur über Menschen die in diesem wir
unterwegs sind dafür brauchen wir dieses
Instrument der V-Leute
ja es ist eine graue sehr dunkle
Schattenwelt die diese Übergangsphase
von Kriminalität und
Verbrechensbekämpfung ausmacht nicht
alle sind dafür geeignet neben starken
Nerven und Planung im Vorgehen brauchte
auch physische Stärken
Ortswechsel Jannis Stamm Muckibude in
Hamburg hier bewegt der Ex Türsteher
noch heute täglich einige Tonnen Stahl
im stetigen Rhythmus gegen die
Gravitation die an den gewaltigen
Hanteln zieht den Oberkörper frei
präsentiert Miami Gianni nicht nur die
schiere Fülle an Szene und Rocker
Tätowierungen auch die großen Narben
sind nicht zu übersehen ich bin bei
meiner Internetseite natürlichen und da
fehlen auch schwer erziehbaren jungen
gewesen die Gewalt eingesetzt haben und
schwächere zu unterdrücken und da war es
eigentlich Pflicht dass man sich schützt
indem man sich körperlich fit hält ich
wollte immer groß sein breit sein
maskulin sein ich habe dicke Arme dicke
Beine breite Schultern große muss
Muskeln bewundert ich bin in der Ära des
Arnold Schwarzenegger groß geworden in
den 80ern 90ern und
habe mich immer an diesen Leuten
orientiert
[Musik]
Jenny wird 1977 als Jan Sander im
nordrhein-westfälischen Ratingen geboren
seine Mutter ist deutsche sein Vater
Syrer die Eltern trennen sich als Jan
noch ein Baby ist seine Mutter heiratet
dann wenig später einen wohlhabenden
Geschäftsmann der zwei Kinder mit in die
Ehe bringt zwischen den
Stiefgeschwistern gibt es regelmäßig
Ärger Jan will nicht der schwächere sein
er beginnt mit Bodybuilding und
Kampfsport die Leute greifen leider
Gottes bei Männern wie mir immer zu
drastischen Maßnahmen
räumte das geht zum Teil an aber auch
böse für mich aus ich habe unter anderem
eine Stichverletzung am Oberarm ich habe
zwei Stichverletzung unterm Kinn und
Halsbereich das mit der Kontrahent auf
dem Rücken gesprungen ich habe 2007
einen Kopfschuss erlitten von hinten
beigefügt durch Marcel m in Hamburg ich
habe zwei Steckschlüssel im hinteren
Oberschenkelbereich gehabt ich hatte
unter anderem mal eine
Auseinandersetzung da ist der
contrahendo auf mich zu mit einem
dekoschwert mich hier an der Ware
erwischt und hier oben den Oberschenkel
mit den sehen da drunter abgetrennt mit
über 20 Stichen genäht Jenny legt kurz
die Hanteln beiseite dann zieht er
grinsend die Sporthose etwas herunter
und präsentiert sein muskulöses
Hinterteil dort befindet sich ein Muster
tiefer gezackter Narben die sich in
einem Kreis anordnen Beucha Verletzung
lassen sich leider Gottes nicht
vermeiden und auch sowas unangenehmes
wie eine abgebrochene Flasche nicht
da kam der Kontrahent der lag schon auf
dem Boden ich mit dem Rücken zu ihm und
da hat er dann mir noch eine
abgebrochene Bierflasche sehr unschön
in den Gluteus Maximus gerammt was auch
nicht genäht werden konnte da die
Glassplitter rauswachsen müssen weil sie
sich sonst entzünden erzieht
Trainingshose wieder hoch und trocknet
sich den Schweiß ab betrachtet sich in
der Spiegelfront des Hantel Raumes es
war für mich immer eine muss erst in der
Security Branche als Türsteher dann
danach Tätigkeit für die Behörden in den
verschiedenen Subkulturen in der nicht
eingesetzt worden bin Bereich OK und
dann gerade auch das Zuhälter Milieu da
war dieser Körperkult auch immer ein
Thema an
jan ist nun Anfang der 2000er in der
Hamburger Szene angesehen er wird
respektiert viele vertrauen ihm doch der
30-Jährige wird getrieben von seinem
eigenen Ehrgeiz er möchte noch
einflussreicher werden noch tiefer die
Szene eintauchen um noch mehr Geld zu
verdienen und noch mehr Informationen
für die Behörden zusammen denn neben der
Prostitution haben sich im Hamburger
Rotlichtmilieu mittlerweile ne neue
Geschäftszweige gebildet der Drogen und
Waffenhandel floriert und wirft
Millionen an Gianni trifft eine wichtige
Entscheidung eröffnet das Tropicana und
ist ab sofort Chef seines eigenen
FKK-Clubs das Problem war damals dass
dafür keine Mittel freigegeben worden
sind eine Behörde wird niemals ein
Bordellbetrieb finanzieren mit
Steuergeldern und da ich aber
mittlerweile ganz gut in der Szene
zurechtkam und auch über die ein oder
andere Kontakte zu Frauen verfügte habe
ich mich dann auch dazu hinreißen lassen
aus eigenem Geld aus Mitteln die mir aus
Menü zu Verfügung standen diesen
Bordellbetrieb zu finanzieren
auf dem Kiez haben auch die Rocker der
Hells Angels Bordelle lauf Meuser Bars
und Diskotheken fast überall AG
internationale gern das sagen ja nie
beteiligt sie auch an seinem Klo er
verspricht sich dadurch mehr Einfluss
und Schutz es ist eine
Verteidigungsstrategie nach vorn nach
dem Motto was du nicht ändern kannst
musst du begrüßen ich haben damals durch
den Verkauf der Anteile im Tropicana
folgendes versprochen und zwar erstmal
einer Partnerschaft die mich in höhere
Kreise einführt der organisierten
Kriminalität wir wollten damit natürlich
dann auch den goldenen Wurf landen und
daraufhin habe ich natürlich dann auch
dementsprechend Prozente abgegeben und
zwar 50% damit da überhaupt auch
Interesse entsteht bei mir ging es ja
mit dem Betreiben des Tropicana es nicht
um Geld bei mir ging es einfach darum
den Fuß in die Szene zu kriegen auf
einer höheren Ebene
doch das Geschäft mit den Hells Angels
platzt die Rocker steigen vorzeitig aus
und wollen nun ihre Investitionen zurück
durch das Ausscheiden meiner
eigentlichen Partner mussten die
ausbezahlt werden ich hatte damals nicht
die finanziellen Mittel um das jetzt mal
eben zu machen wir sprechen hier über
eine Summe von 50000 € und mehr eines
Tages stand ein junger
Versicherungsmakler bei mir im Laden der
die Bücher ansehen wollte und es stellte
sich heraus dass er wohl von einem sehr
bekannten Gewalttäter aus dem Hamburger
Rotlichtmilieu Prozente von meinem Laden
angeboten bekommen hatte die er teuer
bezahlte das Geld aber wohl nie
angekommen war normalerweise hätte der
Hells Angel damit bezahlt werden müssen
das ist aber wohl nicht geschehen dass
nur ein Bruchteil von dem Geld
angekommen und somit stellte sich dann
heraus dass dieser junge
Versicherungsmakler nach kidsmania
betrogen worden waren bei dem Film
Küchen Club Vermittler handelt es sich
um den stadtbekannten Gewalttäter Marcel
m auch bekannt als Knochenbrecher Marcel
so eine betrügerische Aktion mit dem
Versicherungsmakler macht ja nie in der
Szene öffentlich er provoziert damit die
Gegenreaktion und die folgt prompt
nach einem brutalen Überfall in Hamburg
Wandsbek in der Ahrensburger Straße
haben drei Männer in der Nacht dem
Saunaclub Tropicana fkk66 gestürmt unter
ihnen auch der stadtbekannte Schläger
Marcel m die Täter schlugen den
Geschäftsführer des Clubs Yanez nieder
auch Schüsse fielen die Polizei geht von
einer Auftrag Schlägerei aus die
Angreifer konnten flüchten
sein Besuch in Hamburg führt ja nie
wieder an den Platz des Geschehens den
Club Tropicana gibt es nicht mehr der
schmucklose Bau ist neu beschildert die
Wände Lagerhallen weiß ein Zaun um den
Parkplatz schottet das Gebäude heute ab
Gianni zeigt auf einen Anbau hier vorne
der Anbau
war mein Büro da hat sich damals die
Schießerei ereignet die Angreifer sind
hier über den Eingangsbereich drüben zum
Laden haben geklingelt sind reingelassen
worden und haben dann mit vier Personen
das Büro gestürmt und haben da das Feuer
auf mich eröffnet die Nutzung von der
Polizei Hamburg kann sich auch noch gut
erinnern es gab eine Auseinandersetzung
in der Folge man hat dann die Täter aus
dem Büro raus gedrückt offensichtlich
dabei Garbsen Schussabgabe in die Decke
verletzt wurde keiner
man hat dann die Tür zudrücken können
und durch die geschlossenen Tür ist dann
noch mal geschossen worden wo ich
dahinter noch den Schuss ins Knie
abwehren konnte und die Angreifer sind
geflüchtet der frischgebackene Tropicana
Chef kommt verletzt ins Krankenhaus die
beiden Angreifer stehen sich wenige Tage
später bei der Polizei der Überfall ist
für die anni ein Weckruf er wird noch
vorsichtiger als er ohnehin schon ist
doch sein Leben ist weiterhin in akuter
Gefahr er rüstet sich nach gangster man
ja aus und befolgt einige grundlegende
Regeln des Selbstschutzes ich habe
grundsätzlich einer 9mm dabei gehabt die
hatte ich meistens am Körper
versteckt ich hatte zu Hause eine Waffe
im Schlafzimmer und ich habe natürlich
noch regelmäßig die Autos gewechselt ich
habe unter dir Autos geschaut wenn
irgendwas war Bomben oder Zeitzünder
oder irgendwelche Bremsleitung
manipuliert waren also ich war immer
gewarnt und auf Strom
sein Gefühl täuschte nicht denn der
nächste Feind lauert bereits in der
Hansestadt ein albanischer
Auftragskiller getarnt als italienischer
Zuhälter hat es auf Jenny abgesehen und
wartet auf den Abschluss Befehl seiner
Auftraggeber in einem Internetcafé
treffen er und Jenny sich zum ersten Mal
jenny ist von Anfang an misstrauisch
will ich dabei ein dem Fremden Besucher
seine Stadt zu zeigen beide Unternehmen
eine Sightseeing-Tour in Shanice Wagen
damals als ich
Besuch vom Killer hatte der in meinem
Auto saß und ich an einer Tankstelle in
Hamburg getankt hatte ist mir
aufgefallen dass er mit einem Tuch über
die Armaturen
Strich erwischt du überall da wo er
angefasst hatte um ja seine Spuren zu
verwischen und das kam mir doch damals
sehr verdächtig vor da wurde ich dann
hellhörig und zwar dann auch gewahrt
Jenny melde den an der unbeobachteten
minute seinen Verdacht dem LKA in
Hamburg die erkennen die gefährliche
Situation für ihren V Mann der Leute
sahen das damals genauso wie ich da muss
wohl was im Busch sein der Vorteil
damals war dadurch dass er dachte dass
wir eventuell noch weiterfahren hatte er
sein Gepäck bei mir im Wagen vergessen
seine Tasche nicht nur die ganzen
wegwerfhandys waren die in dieser Tasche
zu finden auch ein komplett neues Outfit
und einer Plastiktüte mit einem nassen
Handtuch was mit Wasserstoffperoxid
behandelt worden war war es als
Bleichmittel und
Desinfektionsmittel eingesetzt wird ich
gehe davon aus dass der vorhatte mich zu
Hause zu töten
und gemeinsam mit dem LK einen Plan sie
wollen unbedingt an die Personalien des
Albaners kommen dafür täuschen sie vor
seinem Hotel eine Polizeikontrolle vor
die Aktion glückt aber die Beamten
können den Verdächtigen Mann nicht
verhaften und müssen ihn laufen lassen
ein paar Tage später bekommt ja nie eine
überraschende Nachricht
gegen Abend habe ich dann einen Anruf
bekommen dass meine Vermutung wohl
richtig gewesen ist dass der bereits in
der Verhandlung war wegen anderen
Tötungsdelikten und international
gesucht wurde mir ist bekannt dass der
wohl zwei oder drei Tage später an einer
europäischen Grenze festgenommen werden
konnte und wurde dann zum Verhör nach
Hamburg verbracht letzten Endes haben
die Ereignisse in Hamburg unter anderem
auch die Begegnung mit meinem Killer
dazu geführt dass ich in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mich für den
nächsten Einsatz gemeldet habe und Opa
geworden bin
2010 endgültig Hamburg das Pflaster im
Kiez ist ihm zu heiß geworden er will
zur Ruhe kommen und zieht wieder in
seine alte Heimat nach Ratingen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mit seinem Kontakt
man vom LKA Hamburg bleibt in Verbindung
Anfang 2000 12 Uhr treffen sie sich am
Düsseldorfer Flughafen wieder zu dem
Gespräch kommen überraschend auch die
Kollegen vom LKA Nordrhein-Westfalen der
Plan Jenny soll zukünftig undercover als
V-Mann zwischen Rhein und Ruhe arbeiten
ich hatte angeboten einen arabischen
Clan in Nordrhein-Westfalen hört zu
infiltrieren der sich in der Rockerszene
wenn einem sogenannten Migranten chapter
formieren wollte jannys Zielobjekt ist
der Rockerclub tut ihr Bosporus ein
Migranten Ableger von Europas größtem
Rockerclub dem Gremium MC viele
Mitglieder sind türkischer Herkunft in
der Gründungsphase hat vor allem die
libanesische Großfamilie al Zein das
sagen durch den starken Zulauf von
Arabern steigt dass Migranten chapter in
kürzester Zeit in der Szene auf und
trinkt auch in die Hoheitsgebiete von
den Bandidos und Hells Angels ein für
das Landeskriminalamt in
Nordrhein-Westfalen eine beunruhigende
Situation Ärger ist programmiert
Frank Scheulen vom LKA in NRW ist froh
dass es Typen wie journey gibt die ihre
Tarnung Leben gerade im Bereich der
Rocker, Lied da wird es mir kaum
gelingen wenn ich jemanden platzieren
möchte der Anzugträger ist der mit
weißem Hemd rumläuft und mit einer
Krawatte das heißt da muss ich schon
passgenau schauen wen kann ich da nehmen
und als eines der ultima-ratio was wir
haben ist daneben der Einsatz von
v-personen das ist ein anerkanntes
Mittel der Strafverfolgung das ist durch
Obergerichte durch das
Verfassungsgericht
abgeklärt insofern nutzen wir das auch
Jenny baut sich eine überprüfbare
Legende auf die sich weitgehend mit
seiner Zeit in Hamburg deckt der
Hauptkontakt von mir war zu einem
Mitglied einer arabischen Großfamilie
aus Essen dem Elsen Clan ich fungierte
damals als
Zuhälter aus Hamburg Rotlicht Boss aus
Hamburg der nun in NRW seine Geschäfte
machen wollte weil er durch diverse
Konflikte mit dem Rotlichtmilieu in
Hamburg eine Persona non grata war in
gewisser Weise stimmte das ja auch und
die Überprüfung durch den Clan hielt
stand Giannis erster Auftrag des Clans
er soll denn der Essener Diskothek
essence Frauen für die Prostitution
akquirieren dafür bekommt der freien
Eintritt im Club doch die Clan Bosse
haben knallharte Bedingungen man
forderte von mir gut 10000 € wöchentlich
das sind ca eine halbe Million Euro im
Jahr damit ich hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen unbehelligt und
meine
prostitutions Geschäfte
ausüben könnte Jenny sieht es als nicht
machbar an geht in die nicht ein und
bricht den Kontakt ab
erschloss sich bei einem anderen Gremium
MC Ableger ein
[Musik]
er wird jetzt Drucker bei Bosporus West
hier versucht er für die Behörden an
wichtige Informationen über Club
Strukturen und die Geschäftsbereiche zu
kommen aber es gibt nicht allzu viel zu
berichten das Positive muss man das
endlich sagen war dass man sich damals
tatsächlich nicht einig wurde das heißt
von anfänglich 80 man die bei der
Gründung dabei waren 7:30 man über
hauptsächlich Leute aus Dinslaken
Lohberg weil der eigentlich Präsident
auch aus dinslaken-lohberg stammte er
hatte aber in keinster was
organisatorisches Talent oder auch in
keinster Weise die Möglichkeit diese
Leute zu führen und so war es
vorprogrammiert dass sich dieses chapter
in seine Einzelteile zerlegte die
gewünschten Ermittlungserfolg also
bleiben aus Gianni beendet nach 10
Monaten seinen Einsatz bei Bosporus West
doch eine neue noch gefährlichere
rockergruppierung macht bereits von sich
reden
ein Ableger des berüchtigten
holländischen Motorradclub satudarah
will Deutschland erobern die Polizei in
Duisburg ist sofort alarmiert mit dieser
Gruppe ist nicht zu spaßen
Polizeihauptkommissar Steffen Haus in
Duisburg schiebt die Papiere auf seinem
Schreibtisch zurecht oder Wurst da soll
ich durch Informationsaustausch mit
unseren niederländischen Kollegen das
satudarah in Holland stark verfeinert
mit den Hells Angels waren die haben da
Gutfreund Williams Angels gemacht es kam
zu Tötungsdelikten
und es war so dass 2012
zb5 der 10 meistgesuchten Verbrecher in
den Niederlanden Mitglieder bei
satudarah waren satudarah war dafür
bekannt dass sie im Bereich der
Gewaltkriminalität und der organisierten
Kriminalität tätig waren vorwiegend im
Drogenbereich und im Bereich der
Prostitution
satudarah bedeutet wörtlich übersetzt
ein Blut der the club wird 1990 in
Holland eröffnet die Gründungsmitglieder
stammen von den Molukken Inseln bis 1945
ist diese Inselgruppe eine
niederländische Kolonie heute gehört sie
zu Indonesien weltweit haben die
Holländer Rocker dutzende chapter öffnet
neben ihrem Hauptsitz in den
Niederlanden gibt es Ableger in Belgien
Spanien Indonesien Malaysia und in den
USA im Frühjahr 2012 expandiert der Club
nach Deutschland übernimmt den MC
Brotherhood clowntown mit knapp 30
Mitgliedern
[Musik]
auch Dani wechsel zu den sogenannten
schwarz-gelben in Duisburg eröffnen sie
ihr erstes Clubhaus eine eindeutige
Kampfansage an die Hells Angels
Ortsbegehung in Duisburg Gianni steht
kopfschüttelnd auf dem großen Parkplatz
vor dem leicht heruntergekommenen zum
Teil als Wohnhaus genutzten Gebäude hier
war früher der Eingangsbereich
[Applaus]
satudarah Präsident Ali Osman Ali as
Jedi Raika hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt nur
ein Ziel er will mit allen Mitteln die
Hells Angels im Ruhrgebiet entmachten
dann neuer Rockerkrieg droht endgültig
zu eskalieren
Polizeihauptkommissar Steffen Haus
seufzt und schon damals bestätigten sich
alle seine Vermutungen das hat keine
zwei Monate gedauert nach der
Eröffnungsfeier da kam es zu mehreren
Angriffen auf Hells Angels mit Leder
oder auf Gebäude die von Person
betrieben wurden die den Hells Angels
nahe standen im August 2012 hat er
zunächst einen satudarah
Funktionär muss man sagen der sogenannte
secretary von saponara drei Schüsse auf
ein Auto eines mutmaßlichen
hells-angels-mitglied abgegeben Gott sei
Dank kam es dazu keinen
verletzten noch im gleichen Monat gab es
zwei Handgranaten Anschläge einmal auf
ein Clubheim in Duisburg
Rumeln-Kaldenhausen ein Clubheim der
Hells Angels zum an aus einem Wettbüro
dass am nächsten Tag eröffnet werden
sollte natürlich war so wenn die eine
Seite provoziert hatte also satudarah
gegenüber den Hells Angels dir die
erklärenden Feinde waren dann hat auch
die Gegenseite das nicht auf sich sitzen
lassen und vorgeschlagen da kam es zu
Schlüssel von Hells Angels auf das
satudarah Clubhaus und das macht
eigentlich deutlich dass das eigentlich
ein Pulverfass war
ein Handgranaten Anschlag auf ein
Wettbüro von Hells Angels Unterstützern
in Duisburg Großeinsatz der Polizei im
Duisburger Rotlichtviertel angeblich
gibt es Hinweise auf eine
Auseinandersetzung zwischen verfeindeten
Rockerclubs tödliche Schießerei vor
einem Schnellrestaurant in Oberhausen
dabei wird ein Mitglied der Hells Angels
schwer verletzt er muss operiert werden
[Musik]
wann wollte diesen Krieg aufführen mit
allen Mitteln es ging tatsächlich darum
wirklich diesen Club hier in Deutschland
zu etablieren so ich kann bestätigen
dass von Handgranaten bis Panzer Forsten
über Kalaschnikow alles da war was man
für einen Krieg braucht die Holländer
meines todernst im März 2013 will
satudarah dann seine Vormachtstellung
gegenüber den Hells Angels endgültig
festigen die Mitglieder Schweden einen
tödlichen Plan mit Kriegswaffen Ziel ist
das Rotlichtviertel in Duisburg es ist
nicht weit und Jenny fährt an die
Kreuzung in einem er vorsteht ich
industriell geprägten Teil von Duisburg
breite Straße und wenig Fußgänger hier
waren auch damals die Anschläge geplant
durch den satudarah MC hier wollte man
zuschlagen
K42 Zielobjekte die mir noch am gleichen
Tag bekannt waren ich habe natürlich
dann sofort meine Führung beim rkh
informiert damit die die nötigen
Charms und Schutzmaßnahmen hochfahren
können und einleiten können um diese zu
verhindern und die Sicherheitskräfte der
Polizei reagieren sofort Fotos auf dem
Rechner von Polizeihauptkommissar
Steffen Haus zeigen Waffen und
selbstgebaute Haft Ladungen mit
militärischen Sprengstoff mit dem
Sprengstoff sollte ein Anschlag auf das
Rotlichtviertel in Duisburg verübt
werden darüber hinaus gab es hinweisen
dass mittels einer Hansa Faust die aus
den Niederlanden eingeführt werden
sollte ebenfalls das Rotlichtviertel in
Duisburg angegriffen werden sollte wir
haben durch starke Polizeipräsenz und
intensive Kontrollmaßnahmen im
Rotlichtbezirk über eine ganze Zeit lang
verhindert dass es hier zu einem solchen
Szenario kommt weil so viel Präsenz der
Staatsmacht halten sich die Rocker
zurück aber wer hat gesungen wer hat es
der Polizei gesteckt Giannis V-Mann
Tätigkeit für das LKA droht an dem Abend
aufzufliegen einzelne satudarah
Mitglieder fangen an ihn zu misstrauen
er muss seine Position wieder starten
und unbedingt den Schein Jannis Taktik
ist wieder die Flucht nach vorn er will
den Kurs bestimmen als offizieller Club
Sprecher geht da die Öffentlichkeit Lee
zusammen mit dem Präsidenten der hier
die Raika die Presse ins Duisburger
Clubhaus für die Behörden ist die Lage
im Ruhrgebiet weiterhin bedrohlich der
mit der Rockerkrieg nicht noch einmal
eskaliert greift die Polizei hart durch
und für Jenny wird es noch enger im
April 2013 in einem großen Showdown
sozusagen
unter Federführung der Duisburger
Polizei
33 Durchsuchungsbeschlüsse er wird und
verschreckt haben zahlreiche Haftbefehle
sowohl in Deutschland als auch in den
Niederlanden im Zuge dieser Maßnahmen
wurde auch der Präsident von satudarah
Duisburg festgenommen der Monate später
umfangreich Aussage zu darf Planungen zu
Bewaffnungen zu hierarchischen
Strukturen innerhalb von satudarah
sowohl hier als auch in den Niederlanden
trotzdem mit Lux Erfolg Jenny seine
Aufklärungsarbeit für die Behörden Ford
eigentlich wäre es Zeit für ihn die
Wogen sich Kletten zu lassen aber der
adrenalinjunkie kann nicht anders als
die Gefahr und ja auch Anerkennung zu
suchen ich habe dann nach der Verhaftung
von dir 3 K & Bar OT die Möglichkeit
gehabt in der Rocker Hierarchie im
chapter aufzusteigen ich habe den die
Position des Vizepräsident gehabt was
mir ermöglichte nicht
direkt an den Entscheidungen beteiligt
zu sein aber dennoch genug mitzubekommen
dass man einschreiten kann und auch
dirigieren kann eines Tages weil sich
der Rockerkrieg zu spitzte und ich im
Raum Düsseldorf wohnte im Hells Angels
Gebiet wurde die
von mir benutzte Hale Landesmittel
Polizei Maschine von vermutlich einem
Supporter Club der Hells Angels dem Clan
1 sich angezündet der Brandanschlag
erfolgte auf dem Grundstück meiner
Familie Daten nachts war schlief
natürlich meine gesamte Familie tief und
fest und
wer nicht auszudenken gewesen was da
dann noch alles hätte passieren können
ein Nachbar ruft dir danach die
Feuerwehr der Brand kann rechtzeitig
gelöscht werden die aus Landesmitteln
finanziert der Harley ist aber nicht
versichert Jenny muss eine schnelle
Lösung finden und gibt es Motorrad in
die falschen Hände verliert die Nerven
und tritt damit die nächste Kaskade los
ich habe dann ein Angebot bekommen von
einem hang around von einem ehemaligen
Landstreicher aus dem eigenen chapter
den bot mir an diese Maschine
kostengünstig zu reparieren er entpuppte
sich aber als faules Ei er nahm unter
anderem 200000 € von mir Landesmittel
Barmittel die mir zur Verfügung gestellt
waren um mich im Rockermilieu bewegen
Zug Name an sich
verprasste dieses Geld anstatt seine
Schulden zu regulieren oder Harley Teile
zu bestellen und mit der Reparatur zu
beginnen Gianni platzt der Kragen und
erklärt die Situation auf satudarah man
hier mit deiner 9mm Pistole Villa den
korrupten Schrauber zur Rede stellen er
informiert das LKA nicht über diese
Aktion jetzt ist er einfach nur Miami
Gianni der Lude der Rocker der
Kampfsportler er bricht den Kontakt zur
Behörde ab Johnny bleibt in der
Rockerszene kündigt im Internet sogar
groß die Gründung seines eigenen
Motorradclubs an den mother Rocker MC
Elba hebt sich verliert sich selbst in
den Lügen den dunklen Geschäften und dem
täglichen Stress dann schlägt erneut das
Schicksal zu ich bin dann leider Gottes
habe während der Planung des ganzen im
November 2013 durch ein
Sondereinsatzkommando der Polizei
verhaftet worden Tatvorwurf ich soll ein
brauch begangen haben bei billig
Telefone und ein billig Tablet PC im
Wert von 16 € geraubt haben zwei
Unbeteiligte mit einer Schusswaffe
bedroht haben ja nie sieht dass er in
eine Falle getappt ist wer sie gestellt
hat das weiß er nicht die Konsequenzen
muss er so oder so tragen sein Leben als
V-Mann und Gangster ist nun endgültig
vorbei Game Over ich bin damals zu einer
Freiheitsstrafe von sechs Jahren
verurteilt worden durch das Landgericht
Mönchengladbach der Vorsitzende hatte
unter anderem seiner Urteilsbegründung
damit formuliert dass jemand der sich so
wie ich in den sozialen Netzwerken und
in den Medien präsentiert hat es nicht
anders verdient ich habe von den sechs
Jahren
6 Jahre abgesessen im geschlossenen
Vollzug im Hochsicherheitstrakt der JVA
Werl
der Bundesinnenminister Thomas de
Maiziere hat den Rockerclub satudarah
bundesweit verboten in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Bayern
Baden-Württemberg Niedersachsen und
Bremen Sturm Polizisten Clubheim und
Wohnungen der Mitglieder sie
beschlagnahmen unter anderem Messer
Schlagstöcke Macheten und Gaspistolen
sowie Drogen Schutzwesten und Munition
das Doppelleben von Jan Sander alias
Miami Gianni ist endgültig Geschichte
eine Maskerade die er jahrelang 24
Stunden 7 Tage die Woche aufrecht hielt
dafür zahlt er bis heute einen hohen
Preis seine Familie und er haben bis auf
weiteres keinen Kontakt mehr eine
stabile Beziehung eine Aussicht auf ein
normales Leben sind erstmal nicht in
Sicht er hat noch Feinde und sollte
ihnen nicht in die Quere kommen johnny
hat seine Lektion aus der Vergangenheit
gelernt ich werde auch natürlich durch
die Verurteilung für keine Behörde mehr
tätig sein sein können ich habe weder
geheiratet in meinem Leben noch habe ich
ein intaktes Familienleben und
man stellt sich natürlich die Frage
zu welchem Preis hat man diesen Job die
letzten 20 Jahre ausgeübt eine gewisse
Enttäuschung kann Jan Sander nach all
den Einsätzen undercover nicht verbergen
und der noch Funken seine Augen wieder
frech seine letzte Feststellung mag
resigniert sein Jenny selbst ist es ganz
sicher nicht
Jenny sitzt im Sommer 2021 entspannt in
einem Korbsessel vor einer Baustelle es
ist Pause hier wird eine Diskothek neu
hergerichtet und Jenny voll mit
Gipsstaub von den Trockenbauwänden
leitet den Umbau
[Musik]
das gibt Stabilität der Hühner hebt sich
er muss mal wieder weitermachen sonst
wird es nicht rechtzeitig fertig meint
er noch zwinkert schelmisch schon
verschwindet im Gips Nebel
[Musik]
in der nächsten Folge suchen wir
Erklärungen für den kaltblütigen
Kindermord von Herne im Fokus der heute
23-jährige Marcela abonniere diesen
Podcast da wo Du hin hörst dann verpasst
du keine Ausgabe
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild produziert von den wakeworld
Studios Projektleitung Lutz Neumann und
Simone terbrack Produktion Fabian
Scheffler und Felix Stäblein
Bildredaktion Kristin Wahl Frank
Schneider und Stefan netzebandt Sprecher
bei imo